[Music]
singing remember when you made that
water that water
hey
hey welcome back to a new season of Lost
in the translation
as usual we take a recipe we put it into
Google translate it goes from English to
Finnish to Shona and many many more
finally back to English to give us this
hilariously translated recipe and there
are going to be a ton of surprises this
season so make sure to tune in every
single week so you don't miss out one
thing will stay the same we are
definitely going to keep torturing
Jasmine I'm sorry okay let's get you in
there
[Music]
oh my goodness what is that oh a
surprise surprise like I said we have a
new hitbox and what it means is we give
you the hints in special ways now we
either have to act it sing it draw it
rhyme it okay but now I have to give you
what we really came here for here's the
recipe
thank you you guys picked it
pink pancake
I'm getting sweet but you never know
based on the title why did you look at
that I didn't look I didn't you
literally did roll back the footage
huge shirts everyone thank you this is
the new merch for Lawson translation
suggested by you guys in the comments
from last season they're available now
at shopbusbey.com so make sure to check
it out now we get started let's do it
yeah
step number one we prepare the team
team you ready yes yes half cup oatmeal
one tablespoon baking powder quarter
teaspoon baking powder and a pinch of
salt
am I tearing going up we prepare the
dough let me just take a look jaggery
powder chickpea flour semolina flour no
should I use a hint I think I might you
know I always do this but to get up on
the right start you need a strong
Foundation let's bring do we have a
hitbox song let's bring out the hip box
let's print out the hand box
stop staring at me I will choose Nemo
okay
dude
round
cereal
uh raw soup
gum stretchy uh
spaghetti semolina
based on Memo's oscar-winning
performance I have gone with semolina
flour half a cup of semolina flour one
tablespoon baking powder quarter
teaspoon baking powder and a pinch of
salt I am gonna do one tablespoon of
baking powder quarter teaspoon of baking
soda and a pinch of salt gonna give this
a good mix and let's move on to step two
step number two don't forget to add four
tablespoons the boiling point water and
one tablespoon of olive oil so I have
some boiling water I'm gonna add in four
tablespoons and one tablespoon of olive
oil Kelly and Katie are both pregnant
right now baby's bout to pop anytime
Kelly could go into labor during this
literally she could okay this is mixed
together all right step number three mix
the cookie dough put on tile and attach
the film 15 minute break I didn't make
any cookie dough so I feel like there's
no way I can mix something I haven't yet
made put on tile
transfer to table and attach the film
lay out plastic wrap
and now we put on tile I'm just going to
collect all of this together right now
my confidence level is probably out of
five just because I'm not sure how I'm
doing I don't think I'm doing horribly
but I also don't think I've gotten
everything correct I think I'm gonna
have to roll with the punches today
cookie dough is going to take a 15
minute break and while that's happening
let's move on to the next step step
number four make the water
in a large slow cooker quarter cup mints
and quarter cup of water in a large slow
cooker there is literally a slow cooker
right here instant pot pot
in a pot we got a pot why are you
looking at me like that this is how
Katie's looking at me
I don't look like that quarter cup mint
could it be mint cilantro mint
I'm gonna go with cilantro
sauce are we making a sauce that we're
like boiling down and we're gonna blend
it later maybe
I'm gonna swap out my large slow cooker
with this large slow cooker I just think
with all the
ingredients I just listed I feel like
I'm gonna be blending quarter cup mint I
am doing quarter cup cilantro quarter
cup pineapple Ginger
why do I trust the recipe so much I'm
committing to pineapple
I'm doing a quarter cup pineapple half
inch dry dressing half inch dried chili
I'm gonna do half an inch of chili I
love how you're measuring with your
heart green chili I want to go with
serrano peppers one noodle paste maybe
Tamarind paste there's also tomato paste
oh I'm between Tamarind paste and tomato
paste I'm getting Good Vibes with
Tamarind paste so that's what I'm gonna
do one teaspoon of Tamarind paste two
tablespoons jaggery which I saw in step
one I'm gonna go with jaggery I feel
like it is very hard to translate that
two tablespoons of jaggery half teaspoon
cumin I do think cumin would work
perfectly so I'm gonna do a half
teaspoon of cumin half teaspoon of chai
Masala I think garam masala would work
better here
this is chai Masala I'm not going to get
fooled with this chai Masala I am going
with garam masala I think salt is salt
pinch of hung pinch of hung I really can
only think of black pepper you know like
it's so spicy your tongue it's all hung
out is that what
spicy you're like
hung and because of that I'm going with
a pinch of chili powder quarter cup of
water I think it's a quarter cup of
water all right next step step number
five mix and match
blend until smooth
time to mix and match does this feel
good huh you feel good
spicy chili pepper went up my nose but
it smells really nice step number six
transfer the mixture through a slotted
spoon into a bowl add water or a
three-quarter cup it's like the SATs all
over again okay slotted spoon huh
I think I'm gonna do a sieve I am going
to pour this through a I'm going to lose
all the sauce add water or a
three-quarter cup I assume this has gone
flippy floppy and it's actually at three
quarter cups of water now I'm gonna add
three quarter cup of water
Next Step
number seven freeze for three years
it's either fridge or freeze I
I want to say fridge three years which I
think is either three hours or 30
minutes I think given pink pancake this
is gonna be fridge for 30 minutes so I'm
gonna do that
step number eight put one pound he
wished into a pot and stir well smooth
smooth I wish
for a
uh
it is
[Applause]
ready yes
potato yeah sweet potato I'm gonna
auction off this drawing send me a DM on
Instagram tell me why you deserve this
drawing and I will choose a winner over
here I'm just gonna Mash these potatoes
in this bowl until they are smooth
smooth so far pink pancake seems quite
Savory and I was really expecting it to
be sweet step number nine add two
tablespoon red pepper two teaspoon
coriander one teaspoon cumin one
teaspoon of tikka masala
salt and quarter teaspoon kashmiri
pepper stay with him
red pepper I believe is gonna be chili
powder I am going with two tablespoons
of chili powder and yes I know what
you're thinking that's really spicy but
I just feel like it makes more sense I
hope you like spice ladies two teaspoon
coriander I did see my ground coriander
earlier two teaspoons of ground
coriander one teaspoon of cumin it's
very hard to translate cumin which is
why I think cumin is cumin one teaspoon
of tikka masala I for some reason think
if chat Masala smells so good I assume
pink pancake is Indian
quarter teaspoon kashmiri pepper oh my
God that's not chili powder
earlier I did two tablespoons of red
pepper and I used chili powder but now
it's saying to use a quarter teaspoon
kashmiri pepper this actually says
kashmiri pepper and it only asks for a
quarter teaspoon but I put two
tablespoons have you had cashmere flavor
before no
not spicy
oh it's spicy I gotta get some out I
thought the chili powder was like for
like chili stew you know so I was like
that's fine
you okay let's work our way back first I
need to add in some salt I'm just gonna
do a pinch and two tablespoon red pepper
what could possibly be red pepper
red bell pepper
I choose red bell pepper I'm just gonna
chop some red bell pepper and do two
tablespoons of this stay with him I
think means to mix and combine the
pancake coming together this looks spicy
but good let's move on to the next step
step number 10 prepare the soup
foreign
heat the mustard oil in a large pot to
350 degrees
prepare the oil
prepare the soup prepare the pot prepare
for frying I need a heat Source time to
prepare the soup the soup is going to be
a little oily because I am going in with
all oil I'm gonna do vegetable oil
I'm gonna bring this to 350 and then
we'll move on to the next step step
number 11 take a spoon full of flour
pour it into a small bowl and make a
circle with a diameter of two with a pin
rolling pin take a spoonful of flour
flour I have my flour now and I am going
to pour a spoonful into a small bowl
small bowl what if I put a small in here
and then I press it down make it flat
like this two inches in diameter I'm
gonna try that I got some Saran Wrap to
line the bowl you know what I'm just
gonna roll this out I realize I'm
completely ignoring the part where it
says pour it into a small bowl but we
all learn from our mistakes is what I
like to say so actually
it's just take
some flour and like pour it onto the
bowl
I'm not sure
why am I putting it into a small bowl
what's with the bowl look at them what
are they even talking about I'm going
back to this this is pink pancake I
don't know how thin to make this I got a
two inch circular cookie cutter here and
I'm just gonna make as many rounds as I
can honestly this is pretty fun it feels
like I'm making little pancakes step
number 12. add the chips to the hot oil
until it turns a golden green color
[Music]
with cinnamon holes repeat the same
procedure on the other side so I think
I'm going to take some chips and I'm
going to add it to the oil until it
turns a nice golden brown I think
cinnamon holes is like bubbles but we'll
see I'm looking for it to get a
beautiful golden brown oh it's risen I'm
gonna flip it because it's golden brown
on the bottom this is a nice golden
brown I'm just going to remove it to the
wire rack to drain the excess oil the
first one was just a test so now I'm
going to drop more in I feel pretty good
about this I'm not sure if it's right
but I like don't feel like I'm
completely wrong and I feel like we're
on the right track
could be like a street food my
confidence level before was at a five I
gotta say even though I'm feeling pretty
good it's currently out of four so
you're feeling not great things happen
you know next step step number 13 pour
into a bowl with the help of a cloth and
repeat with remaining bread pour into a
bowl with the help of a cloth
confidence level is now a two
oh I see okay I think it means so remove
the chips onto a wire rack and repeat
with the remaining chips
hey confidence level back to five I'm
gonna repeat with the remaining dough
and then we'll move on to the next step
next step step number 14 mix one
tablespoon of bindi to water uh I don't
know what bendy is I think it's time for
a hint Kelly
I would like you to
sing it
guys I've been saying since fourth grade
chorus why haven't you sung since fourth
grade somebody told me I was a bad
singer and I haven't sung since we want
to hear you we are here to bring Justice
remember when you made that water that
water
that water that water and then maybe add
some tiny little balls to your water
and that's the end of the song
the water the water
the sauce my water is the sauce I'm
gonna go get the sauce
what are my balls
are these my balls oh boondy
it tastes like little crunchy fried bits
it reminds me a little of like tempura
one tablespoon of bindi to my water I
won step number 15 scrape the top of the
pan with a spoon add two tablespoon of
potatoes and nectarine Chutney man
scrape the top of the pan with a spoon
what pan
scrape the top of the pan with this oh
is this like fancy plating you know like
you put the sauce on the back of the
spoon and you're like
so I am taking a spoonful of my water
and adding it here and I'm scraping add
two tablespoons of potatoes oh my potato
I'm gonna make it nice and pretty two
tablespoons of potatoes
I'm just shaping it into a ball I have
two tablespoons of potato and nectarine
Chutney men are these my nectarine
Chutney men I think this is my nectarine
Chutney man okay
[Music]
stop laughing step number 16 last and
final step still in the cotton and good
I'm in the coffin
I don't know if this is right but here
we have it everyone this is what pink
pancake has turned out to be let's bring
in the real dish are you ready no okay
all right open your eyes
[Music]
oh my goodness where did I go wrong
First Impressions they look very
different pink pancake what is this that
is Pani Puri which is an Indian Street
Food very popular I said street food you
did you did say Indian and people have
been wanting us do this we almost did
those last season people have been
wanting students for a long time see we
hear you everyone if you have more
recipe suggestions Don't Be Afraid
though I was afraid today I really uh
season two off to a rocky start but it's
okay I love what we've made I don't know
how I will love the way it tastes cheers
that's not bad you guys want to try it
yeah
stop laughing
compliment me good trip it's good right
it's actually not that spicy okay let's
give this a try cheers
mmm
starting from good that is phenomenal so
what do you think pink panther versus
panipuri 100 panipuri is so much better
than pink pancake but I will say pink
pancake was not bad honestly that's the
fun of Lost in Translation coming up
with new dishes even if they don't end
up as good as the original all right
guys that was a lot of fun make sure to
tune in next week we got a lot of
surprises coming your way and if you
want to check out the merch make sure to
check the link Out Below bye
[Music]
it's not my fault it was not my fault
hey
want remember when you named
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]